[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo zusammen schön dass ihr wieder
dabei seid ich bin Mirco und ich bin
Stefan ich bin eigentlich der Schreiber
im Hintergrund aber weil Toni krank ist
springe ich mal ein Mirko das hat immer
einen kleinen Vorteil für dich okay und
der wäre du bist heute mal der jüngste
hier ahh anyway wir steigen drei Jahre
nach einem Geschehen ein von dem heute
die Rede sein soll da gab es eine
feierliche Eröffnungsfeier die Stadt
Erfurt schreibt am 29 August 2005 auf
ihrer Webseite mit einer Feierstunde
wurde heute das neu gestaltete
Gutenberg-Gymnasium offiziell an die
schuhegemeinschaft übergeben in
dreijähriger Bauzeit erhielt das
historische Gebäude ein neues
Erscheinungsbild so knapp 60 Minuten
Festveranstaltung die in der neu
errichteten Turnhalle stattfand waren
unter anderem Bundeskanzler Gerhard
Schröder und Thüringens Minister
Präsident Dieter Althaus der Einladung
gefolgt in der Schule wurde auch ein
Raum der Stille eingerichtet warum
musste das Gymnasium umgebaut werden
weil alle sich einen Neuanfang wünschten
denn drei Jahre vor dieser feierlichen
Wiedereröffnung war die Schule in Erfurt
zu einem Ort des Grauens geworden
Hausmeister Uwe Pfotenhauer hörte
Knallgeräusche und dachte es würden
Blechplatten Umfallen Notärztin dr
Simone Liebl biereige wurde zur Schule
gerufen an der sich selbst Abi gemacht
hatte und auf die ihre zwei Neffen
gingen und Polizei Einsatzleiter
Hans-peter Golz hat seine Männer noch
nie vorher und noch nie nachher so
erschüttert gesehen wie an diesem Tag
der Tag über den wir sprechen ist der 26
April 2002 ein Freitag das Wetter war
schön und doch wird es wie Bild später
schreibt der schwärzeste Tag Thüringens
an diesem Tag laufen an der Schule die
letzten schriftlichen Abiturprüfung ein
Ex-Schüler namens Robert Steinhäuser
betritt das Gebäude und 10:46 Uhr erst
noch unmaskiert und geht durch den
Haupteingang seine Waffen und Munition
hat er in einer Sporttasche versteckt
auf Toilette wechselt er seine Kleidung
zieht sich eine schwarze Maske über das
Gesicht und beginnt seinen 25 minütigen
Amoklauf Raum für Raum Etage für Etage
durch kämmt der 19-Jährige der
Schulgebäude
er erschießt innerhalb weniger Minuten
11 Lehrer eine Referendarin die
Schulsekretärin und einen Polizisten
durch eine geschlossene und
verbarrikadierte Tür erschießt er zwei
Schüler die sich dort in Sicherheit
bringen wollen Hausmeister Pfotenhauer
erinnert sich gegenüber bildreportern so
am 26 April 2002 hatte ich die Räume für
die Deutschprüfungen vorbereitet da kann
man junger Mann und fragte mich ob die
Direktorin Frau altem Haus sei ich habe
ja gesagt aber auch dass sie momentan
nicht zu sprechen ist danach habe ich
weiter gearbeitet und Telefonat geführt
währenddessen waren die Schüsse zu hören
ich habe es zunächst nicht als Schlüssel
wahrgenommen sondern eher als eine
umfallende Blechplatte auf der Suche
nach dem Lärm kommt Pfotenhauer in den
Verwaltungsakt und findet die
Schulsekretärin die niedergeschossen am
Boden liegt weil er noch einen Puls
fühlt will der Hausmeister
Rettungskräfte alarmieren die können
wenig später nur ihren Tod feststellen
gemeinsam mit der Polizei geht Uwe
Pfotenhauer durch das Schulgebäude er
erinnert sich
die Lehrer die ums Leben gekommen sind
ich kannte sie alle von den beiden
Schülern kannte ich die Namen nicht den
Polizisten kannte ich auch nicht in dem
Moment habe ich einfach nur funktioniert
aber nicht darüber nachgedacht und die
letzte Leiche war der Amokläufer
Steinhäuser lag im Zimmer 111 der
Hausmeister schildert auch das als ich
von den Beamten zur Identifizierung in
das Zimmer geführt wurde konnte ich die
Leiche gleich als den Menschen
identifizieren mit dem ich mich zuvor
unterhalten hatte ich wusste zu diesem
Zeitpunkt nicht dass es Robert
Steinhäuser war aber für mich war es die
Person mit der ich mich kurz vor 10 Uhr
unterhalten hatte als dieser Freitag der
26 April noch normal scheint da klingelt
bei Polizist Hans Peter Golds auf der
Dienststelle das Telefon Gold gegenüber
Bild Freitag schönes Wetter plötzlich
der Anruf es gebe Schüsse am
Gutenberg-Gymnasium damals habe ich
tatsächlich sofort gedacht es gäbe einen
Amoklauf ich habe meine Truppe alarmiert
mit der einen Einheit war ich nach 20
Minuten am Gutenberg-Gymnasium die
Kollegen gingen ins Gebäude als meine
Männer aus diesem Gebäude wieder
herauskamen habe ich in leere Gesichter
geblickt der Attentäter ist schon tot zu
diesem Zeitpunkt die Beamten setzen sich
auf eine Mauer Stille Polizist Gold sagt
die waren einfach physisch und psychisch
fertig die haben so etwas noch nicht
gesehen
so etwas hat man noch nicht gesehen das
war bis dahin in Deutschland undenkbar
John ob das wirklich so neu war dass
diskutieren wir gleich noch aber am Ende
dieses abscheulichen Tages und noch
lange danach wollen erstmal alle wissen
wer dieser Robert Steinhäuser eigentlich
war geboren wurde er am 22 Januar 1983
als Sohn eines Ingenieurs und einer
Krankenschwester er hat einen älteren
Bruder Robert liefert schon in der
Grundschule schwache Leistungen auf das
Gymnasium schaffte es nur durch eine
Intervention der Eltern dort fällt er
bei einer Klassenfahrt nach Brandenburg
durch Gewalttätigkeiten auf bis 2001 war
Steinhäuser also selber Schüler am
Gutenberg Gymnasium er wohnte nur wenige
Querstrassen vom Gebäude entfernt aber
Steinhäuser flog von der Schule weil er
sein Schwänzen mit einem gefälschten
ärztlichen Attest entschuldigen wollte
damit Flughafen auf war offenbar zu
plump gemacht
und wurde zur Direktorin zitiert zu
dieser Frau alt von der wir schon gehört
haben und über seinen Rauswurf soll
Erfolg kommen schockiert gewesen sein
nach dem Amoklauf ergeben zahlreiche
Gespräche mit Eltern und Bekannten
folgendes Bild ganz offensichtlich war
Robert seinen Eltern entglitten vom
Schulverweis erzählte er ihnen gar
nichts weil er schon volljährig war
mussten sie nicht informiert werden
enttäuschte unter anderem mit
gefälschten Zeugnissen vor dass er
weiter zur Schule gehen noch am Tag der
Tat behauptete er zu den Prüfungen zu
wollen die die anderen Schüler ja auch
hatten aber zuvor hängen Robert
nächtelang auf dem Zimmer und zockte er
spielte Ego-Shooter Computerspiele wie
return to Castle Wolfenstein Hitman oder
Half Life aber auch in der Realität
schoss er
robert war im Schützenverein und übte
regelmäßig am Schießstand das Zielen das
gehört übrigens zu den heiklen Seiten
dieses Falls denn ernsthaft Robert
konnte sich seine Mordwaffen ganz leicht
besorgen im Rückblick schwer zu fassen
er musste den Kauf beim Ordnungsamt der
Stadt Erfurt beantragen dass wiederum
prüfte das sogenannte schützenbuch habe
ich auch durch diesen Podcast gelernt
das ist ein Buch in dem man seine
Übungsstunden protokolliert und auch
sein polizeiliches Führungszeugnis war
sauber ja der Fall ist aber
komplizierter denn Steinhäuser kaufte
sich nach Vorlage der nötigen Papiere
unter anderem eine Pumpgun vom Typ
Mausberg Marina 590 Kaliber 12 76 mit
einem 51 cm langen Lauf Preis 664 Euro
mit Sicherheit keine Waffe für einen
Sportschützen warum zum Teufel bekam er
sie dann das wurde dann später noch
untersucht kurz gesagt er hätte sie
nicht bekommen dürfen beziehungsweise
Robert Steinhäuser hätte der Stadt den
Kauf nachmelden müssen tatsächlich aber
konnte er am 26 April mit der Pumpgun
oder einer Pistole vom Typ Glock 17
seine ehemalige Schule stürmen und ein
Massaker anrichten und noch ein Punkt
war heikel als der Amoklauf untersucht
wurde im Nachhinein nämlich das Ende
genauer gesagt die Rolle von einem
gewissen reiner Heise das war ein Kunst
und Geschichtslehrer am
Gutenberg-Gymnasium der 60-Jährige
manche erinnern sich vielleicht der
wurde nach diesem Amoklauf erstmal als
Held gefeiert und dann später als
Wichtigtuer abgestempelt heiße
berichtete in mehreren Interviews wie er
Robert Steinhäuser gestoppt hatte als
der mit der gezogenen Waffe auf ihn
zukam habe er die Sturmhaube vom Kopf
gezogen der Kunstlehrer sagte Robert
bist du das und weiter
hast du geschossen was denkst du die
eigentlich dabei
dann so heiser habe er Robert
aufgefordert zu schießen aber du musst
mir in die Augen sehen dabei Robert habe
dann gesagt für heute reicht es er
heiser das klingt sehr beeindruckend
dieses Szene aber ehrlicherweise auch
fast zu gut um wahr zu sein und so soll
es dann weitergegangen sein robert hatte
seine Waffe eigentlich auf einem Brett
an der Wand abgelegt Rainer Heise gab
sie ihm wohl zurück und schob Robert in
einen Materialraum und schloss ab und in
diesem Raum fand die Polizei schließlich
den Amokläufer der sich selbst gerichtet
hatte Heise wurde erst für
Verdienstorden vorgeschlagen und auch in
der Presse gefeiert aber die Polizei gab
zu bedenken das ist für diese Szenen die
wir eben gerade gehört haben keinerlei
Zeugen gab und schon bald darauf wurde
der Lehrer berichtete er dann selber in
Erfurt beschimpft wenn er z.B einkaufen
ging man warf ihm vor
sensationsgierig zu sein und sich als
Held eigentlich nur aufzuspielen
außerdem musste er sich fragen durchaus
zurecht warum er die Waffe nicht bei
sich behielt statt sie dann Robert
zurückzugeben dazu muss man sagen es gab
später eine Untersuchung durch eine
Kommission der Landesregierung und die
hat den Lehrer Rainer Heise vollständig
entlastet es gab keine Zweifel an seiner
Darstellung mehr aber trotzdem wurde er
durch diesen Rummel auch zu einem
Verlierer des schrecklichen Geschehens
vielleicht hätte Heise sich
zurückhaltende ausdrücken sollen einfach
aber hinterher ist man immer schlauer
und das gilt für vieles nach dem
Amoklauf und da sind wir bei den
Konsequenzen aus diesem Horror Mirko zum
Beispiel wurde er dann später das
Waffengesetz geändert die Altersgrenze
für den Kauf und Besitz von Schusswaffen
bei Sportschützen wurde von 18 auf 21
und bei Jägern von 16 auf 18 Jahren
erhöht
außerdem müssen unter 25-jährige seitdem
ein medizinisch psychologisches
Gutachten für angehende schützen
vorlegen nach einem weiteren
schulamoklauf in Winnenden verschärfte
der Gesetzgeber im Jahr 2009 das Recht
erneut wer in Deutschland eine
Waffenbesitzkarte erwerben will muss
seitdem begründen wozu er eine Waffe
braucht nach den amokläufenden Erfurt
und Winnenden werden in Deutschland auch
vermehrt Schulpsychologen eingesetzt und
vertrauenslehre ausgebildet so sollen
Konflikte und Probleme frühzeitig
erkannt und gelöst werden wir sehen uns
jetzt langsam dem Ende dieses Falls aber
Stefan es ist ja noch die Frage offen
wie neu so ein schulamokläuft in damals
wirklich in Deutschland war also wenn
man dazu Fälle sucht gibt es tatsächlich
Überraschung ich meine niemanden wird es
wundern dass die Liste jetzt von
Amokläufen in den USA Kilometer lang ist
das ist ja auch ein Klischee dass ich
leider immer wieder bestätigt und in
Deutschland finden sich zum Glück
weniger Fälle auch das kann man erwarten
aber der Amoklauf von Erfurt war eben
nicht der erste seiner Art bei uns 25
mai 1871 in Saarbrücken am
Ludwigsgymnasium verletzt der 18-Jährige
Julius Becker zwei seiner Mitschüler mit
einem Revolver lebensbedrohlich
20 Juni 1913 in Walle Bremen ein
anscheinend geistig verwirrter
30-jähriger Lehrer verübt einen Amoklauf
an der St Marienschule fünf Mädchen
werden getötet 18 Kinder verletzt 11
juni 1964 in köln-volkofen
Nordrhein-Westfalen der 42-Jährige
Frührentner Walter Seifert tötet mit
einem selbstgebauten Flammenwerfer und
einer Lanze acht Schüler und zwei
Lehrerinnen dazu gerne meine Quelle
diese Quelle hat nämlich Christoph
Paulus zusammengesucht in seinem Buch
das Amok Basel psychologische
Erklärungsansätze und Täterprofile und
Mirko ich bin ihm dafür ganz dankbar ich
weiß nicht wie es Dir geht ich habe das
ziemlich überrascht ja mich hat es auf
jeden Fall auch überrascht was da in den
letzten 100 150 Jahren passiert ist und
abgesehen von dem Massaker was 1964 in
Köln stattgefunden hat waren die anderen
Fälle für mich auch tatsächlich neu aber
absolut schrecklich und
so dramatisch ganz klar ja und wenn ich
das mal so sagen darf Amokläufe an
Schulen sind finde ich wir machen ja
jetzt wir befassen uns ja viel mit mit
verbrechensfällen für diesen Podcast ich
finde die gehören zu dem übelsten was im
verbrechensbereich passieren kann weil
das nämlich da gibt es einmal die
direkten Todesopfer und verletzten das
ist natürlich dass das augenscheinlich
schlimme aber es gibt ja immer auch
hunderte Kinder und Jugendlichen und
auch Lehrer die dann zurück bleiben
vielleicht jahrelang ja da gebe ich dir
auf jeden Fall recht deshalb ist sehr
auch irgendwie der Punkt mit den
Psychologen und Seelsorgern wichtig die
sich im Nachhinein natürlich um um alle
kümmern müssen und halt auch vielleicht
im Vorfeld hätten um Robert Steinhäuser
kümmern müssen und ich finde dass jemand
mit seinen Sorgen allein bleibt und dann
aufgrund dessen vielleicht sogar völlig
durchdreht das darf natürlich auf keinen
Fall passieren deswegen ist es wichtig
dass wir die Warnzeichen für von
potenziellen Gewalttätern beachten und
die halt auf jeden Fall ernst nehmen ja
und Robert Steinhäuser hat diese
Warnzeichen eindeutig gezeigt aber sie
wurden nicht ausreichend beachtet und
wir sollten eben genau das in Zukunft
tun darauf achten und angemessen darauf
reagieren ja und dann halt Leuten Hilfe
anbieten bevor es halt zu solchen
schrecklichen Ereignissen kommt außerdem
zeigt sich wie halt auch in vielen
anderen Fällen die wir hier besprechen
wie wichtig die Bedeutung von
psychischer Gesundheit ist ja und im
Zuge dessen natürlich auch wie wichtig
dann angemessene Hilfe ist die den
Leuten die ihm genau diese psychische
Gesundheit abhanden gekommen ist total
werden muss ja da gebe ich direkt da
hast du einen guten Punkt Mirko also ich
frag mich das auch ich habe Kinder quasi
in so einer Art Amok Alter ja die sind
jetzt 16 und 19 und und sicher gerade
wenn ich sowas höre frei hätte ich denn
alle Zeichen erkannt der Junge zieht
sich zurück und und da wird nächtelang
da gehe ich zum Beispiel jetzt natürlich
noch nicht davon aus dass das zum
Beispiel mein Sohn am nächsten Morgen
irgendwie Leute verknallt also das hält
einem immer auch ein Spiegel vor auf
jeden Fall ich denke die vorvorteilung
oder dass man jetzt Leute nur aufgrund
von vom nutzen oder davon dass sie Ego
Shooter Spiele spielen kann man sie
natürlich nicht in diese Schublade
packen dass sie dann dadurch gewalttätig
werden ich glaube das ist einfach gehört
heute ganz normal zur Gesellschaft mit
dazu dass Leute solche Spiele das Kinder
soll ich das Teenager solche Spiele
spielen das ist vielleicht nur ein Teil
davon und man muss vielleicht nur
beachten was einfach rundherum noch
passiert wie gut können die
differenzieren dass es einen Spiel ist
und dass die Realität die Realität ist
ja ich glaube das ist wichtig und
natürlich auch wie empathisch sind
Menschen und können Sie sich mit mit den
Gefühlen und Befindlichkeiten anderer
Menschen auseinandersetzen ja oder staut
sich in denen Wut und Hass und und
Gewalt auf natürlich kommt auch dazu
dass heutzutage gerade in den sozialen
Medien wird dir sehr viel Hass und sehr
viel Hetze betrieben so dass Leute dann
manchmal im stillen
ganz viel Wut aufbauen und die kocht in
den hoch und explodiert dann irgendwann
in einer fürchterlich gewalttätigen
Reaktion also schönes Schlusswort Mirko
wir müssen nicht nur auf äußerliche
Unstimmigkeiten achten bei uns selbst in
anderen sondern auch auf das was im
Innern passiert und damit war es das für
heute wir haben den Amoklauf von Erfurt
nacherzählt mit Artikeln hauptsächlich
von Bild und BILD am SONNTAG
hervorzuheben ist dabei der Bericht zum
15 Jahrestag dieses Geschehens den haben
damals unsere Kollegen Nicole Diewald
und jan-langshausen sehr gut
aufgeschrieben danke dafür außerdem
haben wir stellen aus einem Artikel von
ntv.de genutzt außerdem eine Chronik des
MDR und die schreiben wir euch gerne
auch in die Show Notes wenn ihr euch
selber noch mal einen Überblick
verschaffen wollte Skript Stefan Netze
Band Aufnahme und schnitt Toni Heier
brustproduktion durch die weltweit
Studios München wir danken euch fürs
Zuhören euer Mirko und euer Stefan